[Música]
la cámara de representantes de Estados
Unidos suspendió la sesión de votación
para elegir a su nuevo presidente en
tres ocasiones el nominado republicano
Kevin mccarthy perdió la elección debido
al boicot de los integrantes más
radicales de su partido
Brasil dio el último adiós a o Rey Pelé
fue sepultado en el Memorial necrópolis
ecuménica de santos en una ceremonia
reservada familiares y amigos próximos
tras numerosos homenajes en los que
miles de personas despidieron al Astro
brasileño que falleció a los 82 años el
29 de diciembre
al menos siete mujeres han sido Víctimas
de feminicidio en América Latina en solo
tres días de 2023 en Honduras tres
mujeres fueron asesinadas por sus
parejas en Sólo 24 horas analizamos en
esta emisión
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
Estados Unidos porque la cámara de
representantes suspendió la sesión de
votación en la que debía elegir a un
presidente o portavoz de la mayoría que
en esta legislatura pertenece a los
republicanos para que reemplace a la
demócrata Nancy pelosi por tercera vez
el nominado republicano Kevin mccarthy
no obtuvo los votos suficientes para
hacerse con la vocería este miércoles se
retoma la sesión Andrés granadillo con
los detalles
el ala dura republicana se resiste a
darle el voto a Kevin mccarthy y por el
momento no logra convertirse en el
presidente de la cámara de
representantes es la primera vez en Cien
años que un nominado a este cargo no
consigue Que los representantes de su
propio partido voten por él la falta de
consenso ha hecho que sus partidarios se
enfrenten para buscar los votos
suficientes
mucho más gente ha tomado el dinero de
Kevin mccarthy para ser elegido y luego
hay unos cuantos que no quieren apoyarle
Como portavoz así que imagínate Esto no
es nada sobre el país se trata de Kevin
Simplemente no les gusta Kevin Mccartney
El desafío es su postulación comenzó
cuando uno de los representantes
republicanos propuso a Andy Beach como
portavoz un congresista de freedom cocus
que está alineado con las políticas de
Donald Trump al menos 19 conservadores
decidieron dejar de apoyar a mccarthy
quien necesita 218 votos en la cámara de
representantes y hasta el momento ha
obtenido 203 en medio del caos los
demócratas nominaron a
primera afroamericano que asumirá la
vocería de La minoría en la cámara
el escrutinio coincide en que el número
total de votos emitidos es de 434
de los cuales el honorable Japón del
estado de Nueva York ha recibido 212
el honorable Kevin mccarthy del estado
de California ha recibido 203 las
republicanos de la cámara de
representantes están ansiosos por
enfrentarse a la agenda del presidente
Joe biden tras dos años de control del
partido demócrata de ambas cámaras del
congreso pero hasta este miércoles se
sabrá si podrán unificar su voz como
partido de oposición
en Nueva York Sound Batman Frida el
fundador de la plataforma de
criptomonedas Se declaró No culpable de
los delitos que le imputa la fiscalía
entre ellos fraude electrónico lavado de
dinero y violación de las leyes de
financiación de campañas políticas El
joven de 30 años cuya plataforma llegó a
costar 32 mil millones de dólares se
enfrenta a un máximo de 115 años de
cárcel si es condenado por todos los
cargos en este caso el inicio del juicio
quedó establecido para el 2 de octubre
en otras noticias en una multitudinaria
caravana miles de aficionados
despidieron a Pelé en la ciudad de
santos más de 200.000 personas pudieron
ver el féretro del exfutbolista durante
24 horas antes de que fuera llevado a un
cementerio al frente del estadio Vila
belmiro donde fue sepultado en una
última ceremonia privada Andrés triviño
tiene los detalles de La despedida al
considerado rey del fútbol
Brasil despidió al rey mundial del
fútbol
miles de aficionados dieron su última
diosa peleé en un multitudinario y
sentido recorrido realizado por las
calles de Santos la ciudad que le dio
convertirse en uno de los mejores
jugadores de la historia una familia de
parte de la familia estamos agradecidos
con todos con todos por todo el amor por
todo el cariño por el respeto
y bueno para expresar nuestra gratitud
el sentimiento más grande de nuestra
familia es la gratitud de un futbolista
es la gratitud Gracias a todos
las puertas del estadio Vila belmiro
donde jugó Pelé fueron cerradas al
público luego de que 230.000 personas
acudieran a despedirse del exjugador del
Santos incluyendo al recién posesionado
presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
quien participó en una misa informal en
su honor
creo que el mundo le debe mucho a Pelé
sobre todo la dignidad fue un hombre que
nació pobre negro en un país donde los
prejuicios están muy presentes y a Pelé
nunca le importó eso siempre supo ser
Pelé el mejor el mejor y el más humilde
un grupo de Cadetes de la policía
militar de Sao Paulo cargo el féretro y
partió con destino al cementerio
Memorial necrópolis ecuménica que
gracias a ser un cementerio vertical
tiene vistas al Vila belmiro
no estamos despidiendo solo a nuestro
Rey estamos despidiendo a un genio
se merece todo lo que está pasando hoy
en el Santos es del Santos para el mundo
[Música]
el entierro se produjo de manera privada
para familiares y amigos aunque se
espera que su Nicho sea abierto al
público Próximamente para que sus
seguidores puedan venerar al rey del
balompié brasileña
en solo tres días de 2023 en Bolivia ya
se reportaron tres feminicidios uno
diario en Honduras otros tres
feminicidios solo en 24 horas y en
Puerto Rico una mujer fue asesinada por
su esposo en el primer día del año para
analizar esta situación conversamos con
Angelita ballens portavoz de la Robert F
Kennedy Human Rights que nos habló de
las cifras de 2022 y los países con las
peores tendencias de feminicidios en la
región
Sí mira gran parte del problema es la
tasa de impunidad que persiste cuando
hay casos de violencia de género todavía
tenemos gran déficit en investigación
efectiva de hechos de violencia contra
las mujeres y las niñas las tasas de
impunidad en muchos de los países de la
región por ejemplo en Honduras está por
el 95% con lo cual los casos que
finalmente llegan a ser judicializados y
donde hay condenas son muy pocos en
comparación al Universo de casos que se
registran y esta impunidad está
demostrado y que perpetúa genera más
violencia no porque hay una sensación de
de que no va a haber consecuencias por
la violencia que se comete entonces
mientras la impunidad no sea abordada
con medidas más fuertes con mayores
recursos para que se investiguen bien
los hechos esa es una medida digamos que
todavía está pendiente por parte de la
mayoría de los de los gobiernos de la
región pero también hay un tema más
amplio educación no la violencia
machista está muy permeada en la
sociedad y y ha sido muy normalizada por
la sociedad por los medios por las
propias autoridades y mientras no se
aborde también de manera integral
Incluso como medidas de sensibilización
la violencia de género vamos a seguir
teniendo un panorama tan desalentador
como el que hemos visto en los últimos
años
en Ecuador inició la campaña para las
elecciones municipales del cinco de
febrero un proceso atípico que contará
además con una consulta popular para
realizar cambios en la Constitución los
13 millones
450 mil 47 Ecuatorianos estarán llamados
a las urnas Rafael Pérez con los
detalles
Ecuador inicia el nuevo año en medio de
un proceso político atípico este 3 de
enero el Consejo Nacional electoral del
país empezó la campaña de Cara a los
comicios del próximo cinco de febrero en
los que están en juego 23 prefecturas y
viceprefecturas 221 alcaldías
municipales y se elegirán 864 concejales
urbanos
443 concejales Rurales y siete miembros
del Consejo de participación ciudadana y
control social entre otros cargos ese
mismo día los Ecuatorianos participarán
en referendo constitucional que plantea
a los ciudadanos ocho preguntas entre
ellas a la composición de la asamblea
nacional y la auditoría más de 200
partidos políticos que existen en el
país
está usted de acuerdo con reducir el
número de asambleístas y que los elija
de acuerdo a los siguientes criterios
uno asambleísta por provincia y
asambleísta por provincia adicional por
cada 250.000 habitantes 2 asambleístas
nacionales por cada millón de habitantes
y un asambleísta por cada 500.000
habitantes que residan en el exterior
enmendando la Constitución de acuerdo
con el anexo 3 las otras siete
cuestiones que estarán en la papeleta la
extradición de criminales la
independencia de funciones de la
fiscalía la elección de autoridades de
control y los métodos de selección de
cargos públicos clave en la lucha contra
el crimen organizado que desafía Ecuador
el Consejo Nacional electoral anunció
que sancionará quienes incurran en actos
de violencia política de género con
multas que oscilan entre los 9.450 hasta
los 31.500 dólares este proceso
electoral es visto además como un
termómetro político para la gestión del
presidente
quien impulsa la iniciativa unos 13
millones 450 mil cuarenta y siete
Ecuatorianos estarán llamados a las
urnas
grupos de derecha entre ellos
organizaciones religiosas militares y
policías en retiro marcharon por las
calles de Lima y otras ciudades de Perú
en rechazo a la violencia de las
protestas registradas en diciembre en
las que alrededor de 30 personas
perdieron la vida la movilización
también notó con la participación de
políticos conservadores que aportaron
prendas blancas y carteles con el lema
la democracia es amor
[Música]
fin del informativo volvemos en breve